لا يمكن التنبؤ بالزلزال قبل حدوثه لاجل
ذلك يصعب تفادي تداعياته الخطره والتي
تكون احيانا مدمره حسب قوته بمقياس
لنلقي معا نظره عامه حول كيفيه حصول
الزلزال يعرف الزلزال بانه اهتزاز ارضي
مفاجئ ينتج عن الحركه المستمره للصفائح
التكتونيه التي تسبب تراكم الضغط على
طبقات الصخور على جانبي الصدوع الواقعه
بين الصفائح ما يؤدي الى تكسر الكتل
الصخريه وانزلاقها فوق بعضها وبالتالي
اطلاق الطاقه المخزنه في القشره الارضيه
في حركه مفاجئه تنتج عنها موجات تحمل طاقه
زلزاليه تنتشر عبر صخور الارض لتصل الى
السطح ما يتسبب بحدوث الاهتزازات
الزلزاليه تتعدد الاسباب الطبيعيه لحصول
لتشمل الزلازل التكتونيه التي تعد الاكثر
شيوعا وهنا يحدث انجراف قاري وتوسع في قاع
المحيط لينقسم الى عدد من الاجزاء او
الصفائح الصلبه التي تتراوح سماكتها بين
مئه ومئه وخمسين كيلو مترا لتتحرك بعدها
حركه مستمره فوق طبقه الغلاف الموري التي
تقع تحت القشره الارضيه هناك ايضا الزلازل
البركانيه التي تحدث بسبب البراكين النشطه
ولكنها ليست بقوه الزلازل التكتونيه
وغالبا ما تحدث بالقرب من سطح الارض ولذلك
يتم الشعور بها فقط قرب نقطه منشا الزلزال
يعقوب ذلك حدوث الزلازل العديد ايضا من
الاحداث والاثار التي قد تكون مدمره ويمكن
ان تتخذ اشكالا متعدده منها الانهيارات
والفيض
والحرائق وسيل التربه وتسونامي